Are medicinal mushrooms good for everyone? Well, that kind of goes back to this question here.
You know, are these things good for everyone?
Again, I don't think these things are bad for really anybody, unless you have a sensitivity to
one of these things. So in general, I don't think these things are bad for anybody.
Are medicinal mushrooms bad for anybody? Well, I guess the only caveat to that would be
if you have brain cancer, you don't want to use lion's mane. Lion's mane mushroom helps
is a neuro-generative mushroom. So it helps stimulate neuro-generation, which you don't want
if you have brain tumor or brain cancer. So I guess that would be the only caveat to that.
But just like anything, does everybody need with a slow mushrooms? No, I don't think so.
So again, the more things that you take, your body has to detoxify.
So you just got to weigh that out too.